new world the new mmo from amazon games
is finally available worldwide and has
already seen record-breaking success
from tons of fans raving about the
gameplay loop to most of those same
people complaining about the long queue
times it's been hard to escape new world
in wake of its launch and even harder to
deny that this game is having a real
moment so if you find yourself curious
about what all the hype is about but
you're also feeling a little intimidated
by everything that new world has to
offer well don't worry because this
guide will hopefully make everything a
little less intimidating in this video
we're giving you the ultimate set of
tips for getting started in new world so
you can do less searching for answers
and more playing for more of new world
and other rpgs make sure you like this
video and smash the subscribe button
let's start with what you'll be doing
the most in the early hours of the game
questing and for those of you that like
to reach max level as fast as possible
i've got you covered i'm not that type
of player myself but i respect those
that are so after creating your
character and loading into the world
you're faced with a little tutorial
section before heading off to the main
game it may not be obvious at first but
this section is skippable so don't feel
like you have to replay it if you've
already tried the game out during those
beta periods to do this open the pause
menu and navigate to the game menu tab
at the top right of the screen here you
should see an option that says skip to
new world but take note skipping this
intro will cause you to miss out on
getting your first weapon mastery point
however not all is lost you can either
wait until after the fourth enemy to hit
skip or you can skip it right away and
earn that point later on once you're out
of the prologue you'll spawn in one of
four regions everfall monarchs bluffs
winds fall or first light and if you
happen to have a preference there's also
a way to completely change your starting
zone to do this talk to the person on
the beach and complete that initial
quest but do not start the next one
instead open your map and you'll notice
that the next quest is available on all
four beaches now all you have to do is
make the long journey to the beach you
want and then kick off the opening
quests in that territory instead
questing is new world's core activity
and in the game there are four types of
quests that can be completed main side
faction missions and town projects
completing any of these rewards you with
experience points to level up and doing
so earns you an attribute point but
before we talk about the attribute
points let's talk about the most
efficient ways to earn more xp in less
time first off don't ignore the side
quests as tempting as it may be to try
to focus solely on the main stuff it's
smart to pick up the available side
quests along the way this will save you
so much time and you can earn more xp
for example
old me used to do all of the main
missions until they were too high of a
level for me so then i would go over to
the side quest to try to reach that
level oftentimes going back to the same
areas that i just was in for the main
quest so be better than old me grab
those side quests and tackle them while
you're already out completing other
things in the world i can't stress
enough how much travel time you'll save
and while you're already grouping side
and main quests make sure to toss in
some town projects and faction missions
town projects can typically be found in
the town hall and be on the lookout for
very simple projects that can be
completed without going out of your way
too much for example i stumbled on two
listings for hunt boar at the same time
this became an easy killing two birds
with one stone type of situation as now
i was completing two projects with
similar requirements at the same time
while just casually traveling to a quest
and even though town projects are good
to do whenever faction missions should
be a top priority when they are the
first three of your day these daily
bonuses can be seen in the upper left
hand corner of the faction mission
select screen and it should say three of
three if you haven't done any yet
according to the developers this bonus
nets you about 200 percent more xp than
the mission was originally worth
so let's recap really quick grouping
your quest together are key for more
experience in cutting down travel time
main side and town projects are perfect
for grouping together all the time but
your faction missions will get the most
benefit when they're the first three
that you're doing that day all right got
it got it let's hydrate
let's jump back in let's do it
to save even more on travel time you'll
want to make sure you're checked in at
the end of the area you're questing at
this way after you've done a handful of
quests you can just teleport back to
town turn those in and get right back
out into the world to complete some new
ones however keep in mind that the
cooldown for recalling to the end is 60
minutes don't want to wait walk or pay
for fast travel well there's also dying
on purpose in respawning at the nearest
camp or settlement it'll just cost you a
little bit of weapon durability
settlements are also a great place to be
when you're done playing new world
logging out while in a town can earn you
a rested xp bonus when you return to the
game that means that any task that gives
you level xp will grant you a little
more as long as the bonus is active and
now you don't have to feel bad when you
go out and live your real life because
when you return you're getting a little
bit extra towards your progression
another way to level up quickly comes in
the form of territory standing with each
rise in an area's reputation comes a
large amount of xp for your character
you increase territory standing using
all your normal experience gaining
activities like questing crafting
killing mobs etc completing a quest in
everfall earns experience forever fall
crafting something in first light earns
xp for first light and every new
standing level comes with a reward one
of which can be xp buffs so if reaching
max level is your top priority then i'd
advise paying attention to your standing
and picking the xp or standing buffs
when available some extra leveling tips
include picking up notes around the
world and adding them to your journal
these are only worth around 100
experience but if you're out killing a
mob and a note is right in front of you
on a crate it wouldn't hurt to pick it
up plus you get the added bonus of being
able to read it later and get more
insight on new worlds lore
and speaking of killing mobs keep in
mind you only need two light attacks in
order to gain experience of someone
else's kill so if you can manage to
squeeze those in while you're passing
someone fighting then boom you've got a
tiny bit of xp without much effort and
we'll discuss a little more about pvp
later in the video but since we're
talking about experience flagging
yourself for pvp is another great way to
earn extra because of its five percent
bonus
now finally let's go back and talk about
what you're going to do with all of that
experience and leveling up spending
attribute points new world does not
feature a traditional class system like
other games in its genre instead the
characters attributes heavily impact
your play style the attributes available
at launch include strength dexterity
intelligence focus and constitution
strength will affect your melee weapon
damage while dexterity does a little bit
of the same but also improves the
effectiveness of ranged weapons
intelligence can boost the power of
magic weapons while focus affects the
recovery rate of mana as well as your
healing output and that leaves
constitution which improves your overall
health keep in mind that there is a free
respect up to level 20 so feel free to
experiment with your build early on and
figure out your preferred play playstyle
and aside from attribute points leveling
up can get you a second weapon slot at
level 5 your first bag slot at level 10
and your first house at level 15. these
types of rewards continue every five
levels until you hit max level 60 and
earn access to the pv pve mode outpost
rush in rush teams of 20 players from
competing factions fight for control of
outposts that can be strategically
upgraded using gathered resources to
help push the enemies back
and while taking control of the
strongholds is the main objective there
are others spread across the map as well
giving teams multiple ways to gain the
upper hand and win the match
new world's developer has chosen to
stray away from the usual auto attack
combat style of other games in the genre
and instead opted for a more active
real-time combat system you'll have to
strike shoot dodge and block all on your
own while fighting npcs around the
island or your fellow players through
the game's pvp system this system is
opt-in and lets you enable or disable
the feature while in a settlement
however in order to opt-in you must have
joined a faction and reached level 10.
the weapons you'll be using to fight are
split into four categories one-handed
two-handed ranged and magic each
category has three weapon types with the
exception of ranged which only has two
the one-handed weapons are sword and
shield rapier and hatchet
two-handed weapons include great axe
spear and warhammer magic includes the
fire ice and life staffs and ranged
consists of the bow and the musket each
of these weapons can be found or crafted
at their own rarity level common
uncommon rare and epic and each of those
can be found at different tiers however
you need to be a certain level to use
weapons of a certain tier
in a new world there are a handful of
attack types there's slash thrust strike
as well as fire and ice just to name a
few and each of those has a different
effect on the different enemy types so
here's how the colors break down orange
means critical damage white means normal
damage yellow means that enemy is weak
to that damage type and blue means that
that enemy is resistant to it for
example the corrupted are weak to thrust
damage but resistant to ice
meanwhile the lost are resistant to
thrust and weak to ice it's sort of like
the pokemon type charts if you're
familiar with that already and similar
to swapping different pokemon in and out
of the battle to gain the advantage new
worlds classless system means players
aren't tied to a specific damage type
and can switch to anything on the fly
getting all blue numbers from slash
switch to thrust still getting blue
numbers whip out that elemental damage
weapon and try that out instead points
gained through this weapon mastery
system can be used in each of the two
skill trees there are 38 total abilities
per weapon type but mastery has a level
cap of 20. so at this time it is not
possible to unlock every ability
available however it's still really good
to experiment with every weapon early on
to figure out what suits you but try to
settle on your favorite two by the time
your character is about to hit level 20.
this way you can focus on gaining
mastery in those two
higher weapon mastery means better
weapon skills which in turn could mean
the upper hand in combat leading to more
experience especially in pvp when it
comes to armor there are some important
things you need to know about weight for
starters you can mix and match different
weights to your heart's content you
don't have to stick to one style the
combined heaviness of those chosen
pieces are what determine what weight
class you're in and thus affects your
movement and damage output like
characters have a rolling dodge and a 20
damage bonus medium characters have a
quick hop instead of a roll and also
have a 10 damage buff and a 10 longer
crowd control heavy characters get
knocked down to a slow side step but
have 15 percent increase block and 20
percent longer crowd control and a
really good tip to remember with your
gear early on is to salvage
everything you may be tempted to toss
what you don't want in storage or put it
up for sale at the trading post but
trust me
storing it is a waste of time and it's
very unlikely that someone's gonna buy
it because they just receive that same
reward from the exact same quest so
salvaging can free up your inventory and
give you repair parts to help with your
favorite weapons dwindling durability
crafting is essential in new world and
you'll be doing everything from creating
and modifying weapons and armor to
cooking food in order to keep your
character alive but your crafting is
nothing without other skills like
gathering unless you plan on buying all
of your resources and if so make sure
you're buying from a settlement that's
close to those resources because the
price will be less also keep in mind
that each town has some free resources
scattered around so make sure you grab
those if you spot them in the game there
are 17 trade skills split up into three
categories and your level in the 10
gathering and refining skills have major
effects on the seven crafting skills
higher gathering gives you the ability
to detect special resources on your
compass while higher refining skills
makes you more efficient with resources
so leveling each of these different
areas is definitely worth it and all 17
skills have a max level of 200 so
there's plenty of room for you to grow
however i would suggest specializing in
one of the crafting skills at a time
leveling multiple refining and gathering
skills can be fairly simple but due to
the resource pool becoming smaller each
time you craft it can be a little
difficult to level like weapon smithing
and armoring at the same time and if
you're planning on doing a lot of
gathering as you should i'd suggest
investing in some quality tools first
upgraded tools can make the gathering
process much faster as well as increase
your chances of gaining things like
extra azoll
so there you have it all of the useful
tips to help you hit the ground running
in new world if you have any tips of
your own please hit the comment section
and share with the whole class and if
you found this video helpful at all hit
the like button if you didn't also go
down to the comments and let us know
what questions you still have about new
world so we can possibly cover them in
the next video thanks for watching
[Music]
so
[Music]
you